isn't other multiple women his issue is
he's not where he wants to be
financially I think again Society puts
pressure on men to have to be
millionaires like there's this idea that
men have to be so what would happen if
you just said I don't care about the
money like I will I will work with you
like you can do your side piece thing
yeah I'm cool with that too no I think
but it's more him believing in him
accepting that it's not that wasn't all
I want was it because in like the
relationship before was it like did you
is that something you got on him for no
never okay but it's he's con he's
concept of women is women will stay with
you if you have money because a lot of
men now especially like the Andrew Tate
lovers believe that if you don't have
enough money a woman would leave you 100
yeah so this is the problem is me I will
stick by his sideways can I just
interrupt you not to be rude but you're
his wife he chose you you chose him so
what everybody else outside of that is
doing is none of your concern and what
gets my brain is when you're in a
marriage everybody else that really
doesn't matter in the respect of like
you know your parents opinion they can
add whatever but it literally doesn't
matter so Andrews hate social media all
these factors they don't they actually
don't matter take them away and then
work on your your marriage or
relationship together
and this is the thing I can say it to
him all I want but again as a man he has
to believe in himself I can't believe
that a guy would leave a full-blown
marriage just because he doesn't think
he's financially safe
you're already married no it's not even
that it's not even that it's men also
overthink what we like the way we
overthink things have you have you ever
have you ever called him like God on
your knees begged and apologized
got on your knees and said I was wrong
like you were right
yeah we've had conversations we've had
conversations for sure he's not yeah
I've apologized and he's apologized and
we both agreed that when he is it's more
he needs to be he needs to accept where
he is in his life and I can't impose for
example I think a man when he knows he's
got a responsibility especially a father
a child and a woman he wants to now make
sure he's got enough money to support
and again his dreams his dreams
no it's not it's not that he's left it's
more he doesn't want us to get toxic and
hate each other so it's more like if we
separate if he was to call you right now
and be like okay I'm ready to like can
we get back together yeah I'll say yes
so the reason that you're not together
is because of him then it's not me he's
not ready yet yeah I don't think that he
can just leave just because he's got no
money
back no no I think you guys are getting
again it's not that he doesn't have
money he's not he for him having 600k in
your bank isn't enough because he feels
like no no but again again exactly I
can't tell him enough times I don't care
if you're not making millions no it's
him to believe and accept actually do
you believe what he's saying it's just
like okay like it just sounds like
there's something missing from the story
I I don't know I don't know okay yeah
this is where men have to come in yeah
I'm listening does a man feel like women
money is important in a relationship 110
but okay gone if you were now with a
woman but you're not financially happy
where you are
would you break off the relationship no
no you're not a question okay if it's
stressing if it's stressing you out and
you're feeling like I can only focus on
money I can only feel stressed if you're
the reason I'm stressed because I did if
money is I agree with you in the sense
that men do have a lot of pressures but
I believe that's just the way it is and
and men have to deal with that pressure
to become it's part of being a man okay
but if I'm married to you and this is
why I think everybody's gonna start
thinking there's a piece missing because
even as a man and this is me speaking as
a man if I'm married to you the only
reason not to feel the type of way is if
I'm made to feel that way so it's either
he feels that way because of someone
which has to be you or there's something
else missing from the story so now let
me ask you this in a relationship you
have to give time right time and energy
when you have children you have to give
time and energy right if you felt like
you giving time and energy there was
taken away from what your dreams in
money was would you then why did you not
think about that before you're not
married exactly what I'm saying is when
we were initially it was different right
that his goals might have been different
people change I'm trying to convince him
money's not an issue yeah but Eddie if
you were now putting energy in like you
want to put energy in your business but
you feel like having a relationship is
straining your business would you keep
the relationship or would you uh focus
on business I'll do both because I'm
married to you okay now I'm saying is if
you felt like it was draining like you
felt like you couldn't give and when I
say draining it's not that I want money
I want your time right so as a in my my
relationship I want your time if you
felt like you couldn't give your partner
adequate time and you know that's the
only thing she wants from you would you
feel like you need to terminate the
relationship no because I'm married with
a child yeah
it's way higher than that so I think and
this is what we talk about and why I ask
a question about modern women and
selfishness I truly believe that when we
in the relationship it's not about me no
more so whatever it is that I need to
sacrifice to make sure this thing works
is what I have to sacrifice that's my
responsibility as a person who's brought
a child into this world
sorry when you talk about money
I've always earned more than my man and
I've never made them feel
any different less of a man they've
always paid you know they've always been
the man I've never it's never been a
problem and if you're married you're in
your relationship with someone
you manage the money you build each
other up you know if like you if you was
married now and you're on I don't know
nine thousand a year
with you and your wife together working
at it they can build you're not going to
say well you know what let's separate
because we've got a kid I ain't got
enough money and we're gonna we're gonna
come back in another three years when
you've got money yeah you're not gonna
say that I'm gonna work it together I'm
first generation here so my parents
migrate over here they came here with
nothing like to the point where when I
was growing up they had to switch
between he was looking after me day and
night because they couldn't afford a
nanny they work through these things
because I'm thinking if if they can move
from a land with a no to a land where
they don't know and still manage and
maintain a relationship and still be
together to this day for me to come here
and tell the story
there's no reason why other people
shouldn't you know what happened
no can I just say this a million times
over is because this generation hasn't
faced rule adversity and all the
adversity they face is on social media
so for example like you said your
parents left their country and came here
and made it work your marriage you have
to make it work you have to put in the
effort
I think I think there's got to be
something else like missing from the
story literally okay I'm not denying
yeah I'm trying to make the marriage
work right it's I can't it takes two to
tangle right again he it might come to a
point in his life that he realizes
actually Surah is there regardless
whether he's a millionaire or zilch and
then he might be like actually I can see
it yeah but it's very hard especially
the area he was brought up in he was
around a lot of superficial people I
grew up in Hackney I came from like
Eddie poverty whatever like my family
came here with nothing I grew up with
that that's my reality I'm not I don't
care about designer Goods I don't care
about materialistic things he needs to
accept that I don't care yeah but the
thing is you haven't faced adversity
together and that is the problem you're
not facing your adversity together I'll
say it one more time you are not facing
the adversities together and that is the
problem I I'm listening to you and I
respect that you're you've been so open
because it's allowing me to understand
your story and I can see your making
effort yeah but you are it's like you're
missing the part where you have to work
as a team and that teamwork means you
have to put I to the side and make it we
are no no no no
you can
yeah this is exactly the conversations
I've had with him yeah and I've told him
we're here we could do it this and that
again I can't change him if he feels
especially where he grew up in a very
individualistic mindset where it is all
about I need to do this I can't have
help I can't yeah but the thing is
because you've got married yeah and
you've had a child which is it should be
the other way around so he before he
married you he should have been working
on himself and came with the money blah
blah blah and said I'm ready you
accepted where he was and he accepted
where you was when you got married now
you can't go you can't put your child
you know back inside your womb and then
she regrows again but what I am saying
is where you are you have to work
through it together because because
you're working separately and as we do
have to bear in mind that this is
only one side of the story we got a
fifty dollars as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible